I'm not I'm not going to step into the
victimization element of it sure the
problem that we have is he is not
biologically he is not scientifically a
woman he is a woman only on the basis of
his mental illness on the basis of
history we have right now on the line JJ
Murray Goff Rhetta
you're free to yeah go Freda author of
left-hander and London transgender
male-to-female and then Cynthia yaki you
can find her at a conservative lesbian
dot-com who blinds up on the other side
of the issue open out of the closet
lesbian who lines up more conservative
we want to have this debate discussion
Cynthia are you on the line with us now
I am at last on the line thank you okay
good I'm glad to have you and JJ you
were on the line as well okay great so
we were talking about firstly JJ you
mentioned your story how you came out
you felt that you were living something
that wasn't true to yourself he didn't
feel authentic now how long JJ have you
been a transitioned into being a female
eight years okay so a long while now
have you gone through the full surgery
no I don't have the money okay if you
did though million books I'll do it but
you if you did have the money you will
do it okay
now Cynthia you're open out in the open
lesbian I'm not not I'm not blowing the
lid off anything here and I found this
very interesting and interviewing Milo a
lot of people in the gay community
particularly lesbians have a strong
opposition to the current transgender
movement why is that we're lesbians are
expected to be absolutely submissive to
transgenders and they want to be in an
all-female in a female community they're
not women and the ones who transition to
men also are not women that refuse to
leave
although we never we don't get an all
lesbian space we don't get an all women
space and the fact is that your sex is
determined at conception nothing there's
no such thing as a gender construct you
can't change
you can adopt characteristics but you
can't change your sex so so when you say
it's an invasion
you're supposed to be submitted I guess
to transgender men to women are you
saying more so that you think it's
insensitive for a I guess a man to
transition to a woman and then claim to
have suffered from the same
discrimination or disadvantages as a
lesbian like yourself oh I don't think
that's the issue at all I I don't even
want to go there I the problem is
they're not women
so get out of women's spaces and JJ what
do you what do you say to that well I am
a woman so you know I'm different than
than other women and you know one way or
another but you know I'm a woman I'm
treated as a woman and and I I don't you
know do anything actively against
lesbians I'm the president of the indeed
rainbow chamber of commerce sure so you
know we have LGBT than any other of the
letters that you know that they have so
you know for me I represent the whole
community when I'm in that capacity so I
you know I I don't but JJ to be fair
here in front of congenial what if there
there seems to be a strong contingency
in the gay lesbian community who sort of
think that the transgender community
doesn't share a lot in common in his in
his coat tailing on and if you look at
the numbers it's not across the board
there are a lot of people out there like
Cynthia well it's not curtailing its
hijacking and dominating and stealing
the whole thing hang on it's JJ's turn
well I would I would say you know first
of all we're not and I can speak for
myself I you know I know a lot of
transgender people but you know I don't
consider that were that we're hijacking
anything there there are similarities
with with other you know lesbian the
gays and bisexuals and what have you
because there's discrimination
you know when Indiana passed the
religious freedom law that was targeted
against all of us you know it wasn't
against one group or another now let's
let's try and stay away from that
because that's that has nothing to do
with discrimination that has to do with
religious freedom and they didn't deny
I think Cynthia would understand that
too they didn't deny anyone because they
were gay they didn't want to be involved
in a specific gay wedding and well like
I think well in Indiana the opinion of
many was it was intended for
discrimination but that wasn't held by
everyone well regardless when there's an
issue like that
you know the way I look at it is and in
many cases were in it together well let
me ask this because you mentioned that
Cynthia do you see the religious freedom
laws as a anti-gay laws there in Indiana
or did you for example that bakery
well the Baker the pizzeria that said
well we just don't want to cater a gay
wedding they served gay people did you
find that to be anti-gay bigotry Oh
first of all even lesbians would not
have a pizza parlor cater their wedding
but no yes yes the the the religious for
one thing in Indiana they were already
totally free to discriminate no that was
there was absolutely no need for that
but because for them to need that needs
such a law than gays would have to have
some kind of protection for employment
public and public accommodations and
housing which they are not provided in
Indiana right and so I don't but it is a
match for a religious discrimination yes
okay well yeah I just I didn't want to
get off in the weeds I just wanted to
see your opinions to see where you know
you both line up on some issues and not
on the other issues but let me you know
JJ you said something that you are a
woman right and that you're treated
somewhat differently listen what do you
say to someone like Cynthia who has a
vagina and you don't and Cynthia says
it's not fair to say that you're a woman
the same way that I'm a woman it's it's
it's insensitive for someone like you JD
who's obviously very sensitive and seems
to be very caring person can you see how
that might cause women from birth who've
been raised as women who've faced what
they see you know what many women I'm
not agreeing with you know they've seen
I guess patriarchal privileged it's sort
of insensitive for you to swap that
after a few years and then claim to be a
part of their class well I mean
revoir I'm not I'm not claiming to be a
part of anything I'm just saying I don't
woman you know I can identify with a lot
of things that other women have you know
I've been a consultant for thirty years
and now that and now that I am a woman
that you know being treated very
differently and being treated like I
don't know anything is a it's a very big
wake-up call and I you know when I knew
but do you really think JJ I'm just
gonna be honest do you really think
Cynthia let me ask Cynthia cuz I know my
opinion since you do you really think
that people are treating JJ the same way
they treat someone like you as a woman
because I know I would react differently
to someone who I would see as a man than
I would to just say my wife or poor you
I'm not I'm not going to step into the
victimization element of it the problem
that we have is he is not biologically
he is not scientifically a woman he is a
woman only on the basis of his mental
illness on the basis of his delusion now
wait a second though do you believe in
Souls yes don't you think that a soul
might end up in the wrong body no you
don't think that's possible
no I I think that there is something
that I that would eliminate it Jewish
astrology and possible let's not get off
my soul stuff no it's not no no this is
this is where you ask me so no fun dip
did Cynthia and he's doing going to the
Star Trek thing he doesn't even believe
in God so I don't want to go there get
us so far off things let JJ and Cynthia
we're making some good points and then
fun dip wants to go into Star Trek or
the new Star Wars god forbid
midi-chlorian BSO so do you know making
before that about how biologically I
mean you just said something Cynthia and
this is going to upset a lot of people
but you're bold you said mental illness
now Miley innopolis who is gay he agrees
and what I find fascinating not having a
dog in this fight not being gay or
transgender JJ it seemed that a lot of
gay people have said what you have said
that they feel the movement is being
hijacked and and they're not a fan of it
well first of all that's the first time
I've been
told that I have a mental illness so
this is news to me and you know I went
through a lot of therapy when I was when
I was getting ready to transition and my
doctor then my therapist you know none
of them ever said I had a mental illness
I never felt that I did and you know
first of all if somebody doesn't think
I'm a woman you know they're entitles
their opinion when I'm in Sicily J but
what about the fact that you have I mean
you have a you have a penis you were
born a male so let's say someone thinks
but you know that because you asked me
the question and I'm you know I like to
educate people so I don't mind you know
sharing that but well no no JJJ I asked
that because listen I'm just speaking
honestly I appreciate you coming this
isn't meant to discriminate I've watched
your videos if I were to see you I would
think you were were ma'am I mean that's
just and I think most people would I
don't think they're reacting to you in
the same way they do to any other woman
on the street and I don't say that to
just to be mean I say that so that maybe
you're not aware that that's how people
probably see you JJ
well they do right you know I expect to
be to be treated like a woman
I'm addressed with female pronouns and
and I don't think it's anything to fight
for a debate if if I'm a woman that
doesn't take away anything from anyone
that's a lesbian well simply argues that
it does Cynthia well it absolutely does
it took away that Michigan Women's News
accessible and and it takes away in all
women space you are not a woman and
always while we're going to be in as an
art to are not fight that but I'm sorry
biology and facts are on my side you are
not a woman you can you can change your
name I'll call you a new name but I will
not change the pronouns by which I refer
to you and I think it should be against
the law for you to be able to change
legal records to change to change your
sex on your legal records
it is absolutely an outrage this should
not be legal and it's a mental illness
it's called gender dysphoria and it
should not be count out to the inmates
do not get to run the açaí
well well JJ Cynthia's passionate but
she's a very sweetly I'm not getting
that I don't know I don't get to be in
my community because I can't get into
and all lesbian all-female space this is
an outrage well then it is trans people
who are taking this away from me
well lemme prey on the lesbian
communities are most my trans friends
lesbians well let me yeah and I don't
ask you a J obviously Cynthia's passion
I'm truck we're trying to moderate this
here and Cynthia I appreciate it but JJ
I think there is a point to take away
here because you talk about people who
should treat you as a woman or maybe
insensitive can you understand that
maybe there are people like Cynthia
obviously it won't be as aggressive
though I appreciate her passion who'd
think it's insensitive and feel less
safe in an all-female space if someone
has a penis that there are women no
matter what you say JD they're going to
be uncomfortable with that is that
reasonable that maybe be similar to them
with my clothes off I mean nobody has
your clothes on and they see you as a
man well I mean there there are there
are women that look more like men than I
do it's not a contest
I mean you know you do the best you can
with what you have I mean are we saying
that if I looked better if I was
prettier or if I could go through 10
hours of facial feminization surgery
like Jenner did and I would be more
accepted in the in the community I mean
it's not it's not a contest I don't know
about I don't know about where you are
Cynthia but you but you're in Indy I
mean I respect other women and I'm not
at war with anyone I'm in you know I
work for the lesbians as well as anybody
else that's in our community and I'm not
taking anything away from anyone but
what about an all-female space you know
Cynthia has faced she's she never claims
victim status but I will agree in front
up and I have said this I believe that
lesbians are discriminated against some
by some bigots in this country and she's
faced that and I think it's important to
someone like Cynthia to have what they
see as an all-female space and when they
see someone as a man regardless of how
you identify yourself that's how they
see you that's the perception can you
maybe be sensitive to the idea
that there are women who aren't bigots
who aren't going to be comfortable with
no longer having an all-female space I
don't I just don't understand it it's
like I don't see how it would be any
different and and I mean then you you
know if you want to get into into
nitpicking I mean there are people that
are intersex that are you know that have
components of both or you know there are
a lot of different types of conditions I
mean do we have to have a checklist to
say this person is female enough because
of this I mean okay well we're gonna go
to break but I want Cynthia to hold that
thought and actually address that and
Cynthia we appreciate your passion JJ
thank you something we're gonna keep you
both on and I would like to hear
Cynthia's addressing of that point
Cynthia can you stay on yeah okay good
well listen it's just one big happy
family here fund it myself
JJ Cynthia I don't think any of us
shared the same opinion on a whole lot
no JJ we appreciate you coming back 50
and I spoke during the break since
Cynthia is sweet I said let's keep let's
keep this so everyone is talking and JJ
we appreciate you coming back I know I
know it was a it was a rough first
segment but I think we're making some
headway fun dip careful I would have
just run away in fear I I have I'm not
able to deal with confrontation well
yeah well listen you have to understand
- Cynthia is and out of the closet
lesbian who's an open conservative so
I've seen her conservative conferences
so the only reason we became friends was
because she was furious with me because
we were having a discussion everybody
starts off that way the first time I met
you I could not stand you well I don't
Cynthia are you there
I'm here and I remember that we were
yelling at each other at midnight in the
lobby of a hotel in Virginia at blog con
yep and somehow we turned both instantly
at the same time on a dime and just
loved each other I told her that I loved
her and that you know listen the most
important thing for Christians is to
love and even if we disagreed on certain
issues that you know listen that's what
and the same applies to JJ love is
important for agnostics as well we're
not opposed to love you're like a
Scientologist you invent your Star Trek
religion and God stuff so Jay
I'm sorry JJ Cynthia was right about the
asylum but I don't even think she was a
referring just to you it's fun dip and
myself we're the ones in the insane
asylum here so I'm more insane than any
okay let's let's let's let Cynthia so JJ
you made a point before I went to break
and I wanted Cynthia to be able to
address it Cynthia how do you respond to
JJ oh dear God you're gonna have to
summarize the thing you want me to
respond okay I'm sorry JJ what was the
last point JD was making was about what
JJ wasn't about representing lesbians in
the group that you work with I'm sorry
for you know to me I don't remember
being at war with any with anyone
including especially you know members of
the LGBT community and I you know as a
transgender person this is news to me
that we have this much power you know
there aren't that many transgender
people so you know and I don't see us
having a tremendous amount of political
clout unless we're working with other
people because there just aren't that
okay that's a good point
Cynthia go ahead the convention of the
National Gay and Lesbian Task Force was
overtaken by a trans demonstration and
they had to stop business and told the
trans people were done having their song
and dance and that God help anybody who
objected to it got helpful lesbians who
said but you killed the Michigan women's
music festival and you're erasing women
will read you're redefining women why is
it that Christians are worried about the
non redefining of marriage and the
actual redefining of away from biology
away from fact of of sex of your sex
there is no such thing as a gender
construct and it is really a
totalitarian it's people are being
softened up for totalitarianism with the
idea that gender is something that is a
construct and that is imposed it's the
new soviet man all over again and it's
absolutely the worst form of gender
stereotypes which women of my generation
fought hard to get rid of well I think
Cynthia that's an interesting
because I will say this in my opinion my
deal is the language police JJ and you
mentioned you want to be referred to as
masculine pronouns and people now say
that it's hate speech if you don't
sorry feminine pronouns and non-math see
there's a there's a great example I
wasn't even trying to offend and it's
just I I hear your voice JJ I have your
picture up in front of me and it's just
that's the way it comes out I wasn't
even trying to be offensive so for the
trailer okay but a lot it but there's a
movement now to make it hate speech to
ban this is hate speech so do you
believe at all that it's if someone says
hey I don't hate you but I'm not going
to use feminine pronouns what do you
think about that is that something that
needs to change is it hateful or is it
just someone like Cynthia for me I would
say I would say this people refer to me
with with feminine pronouns and they
they they they call me by my name and
the the issue well just say this there's
a difference between people that call me
the wrong the wrong pronoun by accident
whether they knew me before whether they
hear my voice or you know whatever
however it isn't they that they call me
that
and people that are trying to be nasty
to me sure cuz you know to me you know
if I'm female context matters and how
it's used yeah I've had people I've had
I've had people that have intentionally
called me the wrong name in letters in
order to let me know that they don't
like it that that I'm female and you
know if somebody doesn't like it that's
fine but you know I don't need to learn
it and I'm you know I work with other
women and you know and I consider myself
involved in a lot of the issues that
other women have and and you know for me
I'm not what about what about there are
a lot of I'm sorry I need it I need a
gern here this is this is absolute
gaslighting you can change your name
legally fine I will call a trans person
a new name but I will not say that they
are a sex because it is a lie it is
honoring a delusion
and I I'm sorry I don't have to lie for
you and I'm not going to honor your lie
I'm not going to honor your delusion you
are not a woman so what is it legally
you should not ever be able to say so it
people are absolutely out of their minds
if they allow to say that this is a
trans right to have this delusion and
the fact is that the way trans has put
this over is by having psychotic
episodes when they are not allowed to
absolutely dominate and dictate how
everyone is going to behave and and to
force people to accept they're
gaslighting
the psychological term for the way that
trans people operate is gaslighting and
what causes trans people to commit
suicide is the large number of people
who say I'm sorry no I am going to
believe my eyes and not your lies you
are gaslighting and you are a man well
that's an interesting point
I want to touch on that point
characteristics it's not hang on zip it
Cynthia don't you think that it is
steeped in the personality and in the
being inside fun day we're gonna derail
this with your soul stuff there's a
legitimate personal experience it's not
always about bono but JG is talking
about about JJ's personal experience
here and Cynthia is addressing it so
here's my point I think inside when you
are know the interesting to hear that
was just brought over in swarms wouldn't
fund up let me go as Cynthia brought up
a suicide rate JJ I do have those in
front of me and it is staggering now I
know you could say it's making arguments
because of social construct but gays and
lesbians don't have anywhere near the
same suicide rate it's almost 40% for
transgenders it's even higher for ones
who go through the surgery who would be
more perceived as women how do you
address that and say hey this doesn't
share a lot of the same congruence ease
as you know like something listen to be
honest that I suffer from III have
depression but I acknowledge it and I
don't think it's something to be lauded
they're the very same rates and
statistics isn't that alarming well it
is very
it is very alarming and in and you know
I'll admit that that for me I've had you
know very dark dark moments sure because
of being transgender you know in my
experience it comes from two things one
of them is is not being who you are and
then and then when you when you do act
to you know become the person that you
need to be whatever that means and it's
not it's not just the one one shot fits
all but but the other part of that is
the difficulty you go through in society
you know like if somebody says but that
would really reflect across the board
for both pre-op and post-op and there
and it wouldn't be so much higher than
gays or lesbians I mean I know Cynthia
and listen Cynthia obviously can come
across as a little bit feisty but I
promise you she's a sweet gal and
Cynthia you know that she was that way
with me too but Cynthia has faced the
same kind of discrimination
Cynthia is listen Cynthia very clearly a
lesbian if you if you see Cynthia you
would assume so you see Cynthia with her
partner so she's faced that same
discrimination but the suicide rate is
nowhere near as high why is there such a
wide gap there well I you know I don't
know why there are so many I you know I
do know that it's a very big problem
there's not as much help when you have
people at tech like it you know in this
case today if people are attacking me
because they're saying we're arguing
with you because because we're saying
that you're not what you think what you
think you are and you're taking away
from the rest of us by existing no
they're not though they're saying we
don't have no such thing this is a fact
you are not a woman you will never be a
woman no surgery no drug no clothes no
happy feeling of femininity is going to
make you a woman this is a fact and what
causes suicide among trans people is to
go further and further down that road to
be an enabled and then to find out no
they didn't because they didn't actually
get to change sex their body is still
going to be insisting that they are
the sex that they were that they were
born they were trying to externalize
what would be make them what would make
them fulfilled and happy and then it
doesn't happen so it's the left and
progressives who are enabling this
gendered construct baloney and who are
enabling this delusion that surgery is
going to make you at a different sex
which is absolutely false and then of
course it doesn't happen how does that
shatter people and of course there is no
reason for people to go along with the
transgendered gaslighting you are not
you weren't asking people to accept
something that is not that's the point
right there Cynthia one second one
second fundament have been before he
does I think we've touched on an issue
JJ you're saying people are discriminate
against what you want to be I think what
Cynthia is saying and what I would agree
was on her side as she's saying no we
don't have to accept you redefining
something fun dip go but don't you think
that the personality how the person
feels matters I mean when I think about
what it would be like to to have your
your the very fiber of your being you
know different from your body that
breaks my heart I think it breaks a lot
of people's hearts but it also breaks
people's hearts if they have if they
believe something to not be true in
other ways I mean JJ what about this you
know there are a lot of people that once
you start chopping yourself up and the
fact that they have to add drugs in
order to complete this it means that it
that their their mental delusion is just
not enough well I think there's an irony
here Cynthia tell you that biology
really has something to do with this
well I think there's a hold on hold on
fund up hold on fund it and hold on
Cynthia hold on Cynthia hold on fund I
do think there's an irony here JJ could
you agree for example Caitlyn Jenner now
okay we constantly fight against the
idea of this social construct of beauty
in this unrealistic standard of beauty
and we tell women they shouldn't have to
get plastic surgery and they shouldn't
do drugs to change who they are but then
it's supposed to be lauded and given
praise when when you do it isn't that a
little bit of an irony well I would say
this a big breakthrough for me was when
I stopped trying to figure out what
happened
then what caused it mm-hmm and just said
you know I just need to do whatever I
need to do and and then and then that
was you know that was how I went forward
and you know I didn't get a new card in
the mail you know saying that that I was
female I thought you're gonna say new
Costco card because those are fantastic
and I will tell you this you know I have
not experienced what Susie is talking
about but she has JJ so can you maybe
say you you're insensitive to people
like Cynthia but you say she's
insensitive but you're both maybe a
little insensitive to each other I'm not
insensitive I just haven't seen it and
you know when I interact with people I
expect to be treated you know with
respect and people calling me the
correct name what have you and and I you
know to me it's it's not a very
interesting debate on my side to say you
know I'm not going to accept you as a
woman I'm like well okay but you know
that's not the way that I like to be
treated and that's not what I'm
experiencing you know here maybe we're
more progressive down here in Indiana
but but well listen to me I will tell
you that it really be the recommendation
for this show I don't care if you run
around in a dress I don't care if you
feel like a pretty pretty princess I run
around in a dress girl you end it to
your heart's content but use the men's
room play men Lords you have to you you
cannot change your driver's license you
cannot change your birth certificate you
are a man what about anyone for anyone
and let me ask you this that's true
seriously now I'm supposed to give
everything up because it was a joke yes
Cynthia that was that I think it was a
joke of the bathroom here that fund it
has to clean is like a Turkish prison I
didn't get a chance to hear I listened
to the one yeah I listened to the one
where you
for the piano that you have to go I tell
you what though listen JJ and then we
have to go to a break here I don't know
if we can can we continue this into the
next segment or it's gonna be short
anyway it'll be a short segment but
we've got some commercials here okay hey
do you mind staying through the next
segment both of you and then we'll wrap
it up and you can give your closing
arguments can you both do that great
thank you so much we'll be right back
ladder with Crowder appreciate it great
we come back with lesbian and
transgender activists and the ultimate
stripper song poisoned by Alice Cooper
plays so before we go JJ cynthia thank
you so much for coming back JJ you just
made the point about using a woman's
restroom and that you you made your
arguments to why you feel that way well
let me kind of give that to Cynthia
before I do I mean it's a place where
women feel sexually vulnerable it's a
place where sexual assault often occurs
and at a certain point my only argument
yours you're discriminating against
somebody and in this case you're
discriminating against the vast majority
of women who feel unsafe who feel
uncomfortable in order to accommodate
you know less than 1% of the population
with transgender people so either way
you're discriminating on some side well
women feel unsafe with it and so you're
being insensitive yes they do statistic
JJ statistically they do it can't all be
personal we have to look at some stats
and I appreciate they wouldn't tell you
JJ they wouldn't tell you they wouldn't
do my wife wouldn't say anything and I
guarantee she would feel very
uncomfortable Cynthia you can address
the the point all right trans people
need to use we have to make it a lot of
trans people have to use the facilities
the sports the prisons any sex
segregated facility it has to match
their birth sex now what about on the
flip side those say you've got somebody
who is transitioned female to male
coming in to the ladies room with a bald
head we get the point wrong arms you
know that's that's not gonna be
something by the way I've never seen a
female to male transgender ever who
looked even remotely large it wouldn't
necessarily know
buck-buck the guy who hates me the most
famous trans male porn yeah you would
know you would know it's different bone
structure Cynthia but what do you say to
that
I I would actually prefer that all trans
people use the men's room if I were
getting to make a lot and yeah but
that's not rational
testosterone going both ways for the
male to female has had the advantage of
a lifetime of testosterone it changes
the bone structure and it's an enormous
advantage and also just as an
expectation to dominate that they have
and an absolute unwillingness to take no
for an answer
I mean absolute sounds like you though -
but but but for female to male once they
start taking testosterone they get that
- so my preference would be that they
use they all all trans people use the
men's room or what I'm willing to
compromise that they use the facilities
of their birth sex but not okay so you
want a separate drinking fountain - oh
shut up fun dip don't try and equate a
lesbian conservative with racism that's
ridiculous what do you say to that JJ
well I think there is a lot of
similarity with with racism of people
saying if you are this then you can't do
that it's um you know for me if I went
to the men's room my life would be in
danger the only way JJ could have a
similarity with racism is if gender is
biologically determined like race are
you saying that gender is biologically
determined just like race I don't know
I'm not sure what the reason is okay I'm
just saying you go with what you get and
and and I don't know I I'm just having a
hard time with the anger and the outrage
you know my my doing something I don't
think took away from anyone else it just
made me a lot better and well I think
Society I think we're having a
disconnect here JJ where you're only
talking about personal experiences which
granted are going to be seen through the
lenses of the lens of your life and
Cynthia is talking about societal
ramifications but JJ we have to let you
both go and we do appreciate you both
coming on JJ where can people best find
you firstly go and like that
okay Jenner has a million likes I have
170 so and then Cynthia where can people
find you best I am most frequently on
Twitter my
at conservative less and my blog is to
contribute of lesbian calm if people
would like to help fund me if you help
me write a book about the attitudes and
positions I've just discussed I'll put
up a post later today to take donations
for Kindle formatting and editing and so
on okay thank you both both of you very
much we want to have both of you back on
soon fun dip what
there's also left-hander and no no no
anthem plug earthquake you gotta check
that out too though okay great thank you
so much JJ thank you we appreciate it
Thank You Cynthia louder with Crowder we
will be back after this word from people
who keep the lights on and who knows
maybe some people writing these ads are
lesbian and/or transgender and we're all
just one big happy family louder with
Crowder
stay tuned hey if you like this be sure
to subscribe by clicking my face here on
YouTube clicking the video next to me or
subscribe on iTunes SoundCloud or louder
with Crider comm it's all free and I'm
sure many of you will still find a
reason to [ __ ] about it